hey sanju couch here as you know it's
another Tuesday another tie your Tuesday
and then this week we're gonna be
looking at GDP our violations
I'm not really familiar with GDP are
except I did hear about it in the the
make me smart podcast with Kyra stall
but the GPR is actually general data
protection regulation so it's most about
data privacy specifically in the EU and
the I guess European economic areas so
it's about basically violation of
personal data and rate the regulatory
environment there's only two little
files and they're not too bad either so
we're gonna open up a markdown and I'll
just do that I'll call this tidy to use
they GDP are cool obviously going in the
Tigers and we'll load in these texts and
CSV files or actually there are TSP
files so just do a basic look at let's
just do a basic examination of GDP are
violations so it comes with an ID a
picture I guess the name of the the EU
countries that got the violations the
price of the violation who was assigning
who is the authority for it
what's your so next home
next fields oh we have a date for it the
controller article violated and I guess
that's it so it's not it's not a lot of
information for this for this last one
oh yeah so they have a source and
summary notated for us kind of a summary
of it um
okay cool
we should probably look at the actual
violation so it's maybe summarize the
total fines that each country has
received so we'll do a group by
summarize
total equals some price and group it and
it was just you know plot it out so x
equals three order name total y equals
total yeah what's their genome calm okay
and then we'll do a cord flip yep core
flip okay so I guess let's you so so
France has the most amount of the most
amount of fines or the highest highest
price of fines let's look at number of
fines so this is as France and France
Italy and Germany have the highest
amount of fines now just look at total
fines so we're just gonna copy this and
instead of total will say a number of
fines and we'll just use is what we'll
just do uh actually let's do yeah count
name count name name and then name and
and okay so basically we were just
plotting out the frequent the amount of
fines or the number of actual violations
they have so Spain Germany and Romania
have the most have been heaven fine the
most frequent frequently okay okay well
that's I mean that that's not very
interesting like that's that's just a
generic I Tuesday thing right there
let's look at F of GDP our text which I
think would be kind of cool little good
so
we have a chapter title article title
sub article GDP our text and href so
like all link probably to it so I want
to okay
so we have a we have a sub article how
many let's do select chat up select a
chapter how many chapters are there
right just think all right so there's 11
chapters how many how many articles are
there there's 99 articles and then how
many sub articles are there so argh
and then there's 13 so I bet this sub
article is a part of the actual article
so let's see article okay yep so
articles have sub articles okay now now
that we actually have I guess we know we
have like text for I guess every sub
article stuff like that basically for
everything so we have the total text for
each chapter each article and also it
for each sub article we should actually
look at write the violations and what
they reference so so the each Sam hm row
is one violation and we have the article
violated so its article 28 GDP our
article 13 article 5 I'm gonna assume a
seeming like sub article 1 and also we
can see that there's multivalued
attributes in here I'm assuming they're
multi value where it's like okay they
violated these was it one two three
these four so we got to do for the GDP
our violations is actually let's uh
let's first kind of make a foreign so
because what I'm thing is we might be
able to join some of these things
together so I don't think we're gonna
need I think we're gonna just select I'm
gonna select name price what else do we
need name price article violated what
else do we need um alright I don't I
don't know any think I'm gonna do
anything with Youth Authority
maybe type I don't
and maybe type okey one and summary okay
so I'm gonna stew type in summary I'm
not sure if full user or not type and
submarine pop okay so since these are
multivalued which I'm gonna assume
they're multivalued I'm not I'm not sure
I'm gonna see let me see if there's like
anyone with the same article violation
and see the cost of it so I'm just gonna
do this so I'm gonna do this separate
rows um and we're gonna separate the
article violated article violating um
field and we're gonna separate it using
was it the the - simple oh wait but
since this is like an actual like I
think regular expression character we're
not to be the escape things with just
the two backslashes so there we go we
have our GDP are things split
additionally what we kind of want
because we know we have our articles
right so if we look at here are we look
at articles so our articles right we
need to extract this when you extract
that so what I'm gonna do is you Tate
and I'll say article equals and then
we're gonna say x ER extract article
violated article violated and the
pattern will be it'll be since we see
how that there's just there just two
numbers right so we're gonna try to find
the first two numbers however sometimes
sometimes it's gonna be a single number
so what I'm gonna say is
like we know if it has two numbers as
one number I know so we can just say the
second number is optional but we're
still gonna look for it so I'm going to
do is 0 through 9 those are the numbers
were looking for and then again we're
gonna say the next digit has to be 0
through 9
oops we'll say it's optional which is I
think done with a question mark so let's
see if that works
actually I'm gonna so 28 12 13 5 that's
why I should be 28 12 35 sweets okay we
got that sweet um I'm not gonna remove
I'm gonna remove type in summary I don't
I want to deal with that okay
Oracle violated price stuff like that
will kind of worry about that later I
just want to kind of get the articles
first so now we have the actual thing
for gdpr by ocean so we'll say GDP are
violations with the extracted article
and now I'm actually gonna make kind of
like a GDP our text key so that way we
can kind of have like okay select
article and then article title and then
what's it and GDP Ardex why they call it
G wait they call it GDP our text okay
that's gonna make GDP our text and we're
gonna call this text equals GDP our text
because I don't really like how the the
object or the data frame name has the
same field name as it especially when
it's kind like the main thing of it so
we have this week so we have a key key
to link on the violations with text
great um let's see what else can we do
let's we're kind of like well what I'm
trying to do right now is kind of prep
everything before we start doing
anything crazy
okay also I think we can do select -
article violated okay so now we just
have name price article actually I want
date to date okay yeah so we have date
so now we have that I want to look at
I'll say GDP our violation Gd I'll say
GDP our price yeah GDP our price okay GD
e PR price yeah we probably see the
distributions of like the alcohol
pricing and stuff or the fine so we'll
do ggplot yes X equal name y equals
price G um box plot was cord flip
probably gonna do a yeah so we're going
to do a scale X reordered scale Y scale
Y log 10 what am I talking about
there we go and we'll say color equals
name and then show doubt legend it goes
folks so you okay man now count now I'm
good I'm good okay so we can see that
how I wish could I can't want to reorder
the things but I just want to look at
this just to get a baseline of like
who's getting the most funds we can see
was it Italy has has a huge distribution
huge width same with I'm Germany they
have a huge huge with you know in key
knows pretty much in the you know
they're pretty consistent I guess with
their violations or they might just not
have a lot of violations I'm gonna do a
place genome genome jitter
alpha equals 0.1 plus I just want to
like look at okay so just kind of a guy
density of it
and showed up watching okay just to get
a density thing where you know see here
there Spain is getting a lot of
violations right whereas uh you know you
came might not have as many I'm gonna
just make sure I'm not talking crazy
so yeah UK doesn't have that many okay
so we kind of see about the violations
um since now we actually have GDP our
text stuff um how about we start doing
some like text analysis stuff I think
it'd be interesting to just look at kind
of like summarize all this text because
I don't really want to look at all this
stuff there's a lot of articles which
when you look at this it's it's like
there's a lot you can you can basically
use these articles as documents so
that's what we're gonna do we're just
gonna I'm gonna select the article text
we don't really need to do I don't think
we need is just distinct we don't need a
sting so we're gonna do this we're gonna
be actually or in the famous package the
tidy text package and the tempo and the
tie a text package is is this by Julie
silly and David Robinson who are very
popular are people they also have I
think work in our studio or at least I
know Julia so he does and she does the
same tidy Tuesday videos and David
Robinson also does a lot of cool videos
too and he he does some royal really
interesting I'm tired Tuesday stuff
especially with like um functional
programming stuff and optimization water
okay so we have our text we're gonna use
the on nest on nest tokens function and
we first give an output so we'll call
this um we'll call it tokens and then
our input is
text and our token is words right so now
we have 20,000 words correspond to each
article okay and we're gonna call this
GDP our words right really simple and
yeah we're not gonna do any aggregation
yet because I think there's not a lot of
words so we're also going to do GDP our
diagrams this time we're gonna we're
gonna also just you know do everything
ahead of time so we don't have to wait
for anything crazy so instead of token
forwards will say engrams all right and
we'll equal to two yeah yep - we're
gonna do the same thing right and this
time we'll do three and we'll call us
trigrams okay so did you put our words
let's just do a basic backwards analysis
so first I want to say conversion of and
grams okay number one thing you deal
with text mining is you count the words
in the word frequencies and we can see
that it's just completely pointless and
we don't need any of this stuff into it
so we'll say we'll use the internal word
internal function or internal data from
the Thai text and always say we're gonna
remove all stop words using an T join
[Music]
stop word word okay
Oh God okay bye
equals tokens equals word right okay
that's project I switch it to word but
I'll do all worried about that later
actually no I'm just gonna worry about
that later okay so let's just do a slice
one to ten
oh yeah we'll do a group by our article
top and and N equals five
well GG plotted out y equals and I will
say fill equals oh I know there's gonna
be a ton of articles so we're not gonna
do that we're just gonna look at the top
five we'll look at the top five words
that seems fine enough I'm top five four
okay we'll just look at the top five
words so data supervisory means personal
and data that makes a lot of sense
because um we have a lot this thing is
supposed to be about data I'm actually
just gonna remove the articles since now
that I think about I don't really need
it right now cuz we're just gonna look
at basic things so data article
processing supervisory and personal
great okay so G GDP are words what we
should also do is we should do a buy
gold will do on what we should be doing
is we should do a basic sentiment
analysis so we'll say I'm get was it get
sentiments lexicon equals being
oh yeah and then get some mints and they
do word I'm gonna chain just a word so I
don't don't worry about this garbage
which I'm not sure if you really should
be doing but we're gonna call it and say
it's fine
token ante joining word go yeah so so we
got that and we'll say I will group by
article and then count sentiment all
right and then we'll do one group
actually we'll just do a will do group i
sentiment and then well i want to see is
which article which article has the
highest sentiment and which highest
pauses positive words and which chart
across the highest negative words so
we'll do on filter and equals max and
okay so articles seventy in Article III
those are the words I have the most
polarizing stuff we could also do a top
end thing which I think just probably
made for a tense so we'll save top three
of all of it
cool so the these articles these these
articles have the most amount of
sentiment so it's positive
what yeah positive and negative
okay um let's see here one thing that
would be kind of interesting is okay I
don't want to I don't want to read GDP
GDP our text right that's that's gonna
be a mess right if I do like you know
soul select select
right it's it's it's I don't know I
don't think it's not meant to be read
especially with this this project you
know you can't really read a lot of text
in in are the manual way they want you
to really like go through
programmatically so what I'm gonna do
okay is I think what we should do is a
top do some topic modeling which topic
modeling is essentially like a
unsupervised learning method to
basically create groupings of text data
and figure out like literal topics
through a distance relative distance
using different statistical techniques
and I really the most common one is a
it's called it's called a latent
something like that's it's a latent
something it's called LD a basic LD a
topic modeling it's called latent
dirichlet allocation Derek Derek Derek
Derek
I don't know French let's look it up oh
god who is who's I serve who's it by I
have no idea
probably state using a darish let show
at two prior so they're basically using
some type of Bayesian process I'm not
sure if they're using like a good
distance it's like a little like a
bigram or I don't know but we don't with
school about tire you text is you don't
really have to know a lot of math do
that you know it'd be you know a crazy
math nerd to do that so that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna analyze based
on a word by word basis for the topic
modeling so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna grab gdpr words right I'm just
gonna count it by article for every
article we counted by the word and then
we're gonna do an Lda I know we're gonna
make it into a I cast when we get a
document term matrix and it seems pretty
weird why we would do this because we
already have in a tidy format where
article were
frequency but we needed to do it for I
guess delayed era shallot or the LDA
type of modeling to do its work and a
document turn matrix is how it really
does its so we're gonna have to specify
a dark hour document which is an article
so we have multiple articles and every
article has multiple words and
frequencies so then we have our was it
our token token music cast cast the term
so I called
so we have our term she goes word and
our what our value which is and it
creates a docking term matrix so we're
gonna call that GDP GDP our DTM GDP our
DTM that's cool now is we can just
create a topic model right so we'll say
GDP our DTM and our arm I guess how many
documents we wanted to do we want to
create I'm not sure if there's actually
a set way to do it but we're gonna do
ten documents 10 10 topics let's see if
there's if there's a way to do it I just
want to make sure that also and we'll
use a logical we will soon see that
since a large number okay
so there's not really a way to do it so
we'll do kegels 10 and we'll just make
sure that works okay and it does gdpr
and we'll say topic model will assign
that so it creates a tail the LDA model
using the ve m algorithm what who really
cares right that's you know this isn't a
math class okay so we're creating our
topic model we're gonna have a topic
model object alright so we have that and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna use
we're gonna use this topic model object
to gather things so the first thing that
we want to do is actually and like look
at our topics and what words are in our
topics so we're gonna do is what terms
make up a topic
stop so we're gonna do use a tidy format
because it's a tie it's a tidy text and
use the tidy function to really do these
things and there's all it's all very
streamlined its honesty its right one of
the best house you can ever have but
ever used and well so we'll use tidy I
am on a tangent but what we're gonna do
is we're gonna tie the top model and
we're gonna create a matrix out of it
using a gamma using no you're going to
use a beta beta and what this does is
the basic fear calculates each terms
probability for being in that topping
now what we're gonna do is we're gonna
group by right we're in a group by topic
we're gonna do we're gonna find the top
with the top five terms so we'll say was
it beta and then it's N equals ten
okay
actually I think well since we have 10
tops with you 5 okay let's see if
there's anything crazy that we have in
here you know what you see right here
there's a lot of um a lot of uh stop
words so what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually gonna do it I'm gonna remove
those stop words oh no I'm not gonna
reduce that topic probabilities to I
mean that the topic models so instead of
10 tops for and reduce it to 5 topics ok
and now since we have our topic school
to achieve plot it x equals turn 3 order
within so what this does is it kind of
reorders the column charts um when you
facet and it's really common to do the
typical core flipped column chart and do
a facet fast wrap of the topics so this
this makes it a little cleaner
facet wrap topic scales equals 3 plus
theme legend legend position equals 9 ok
so we got that and I'm gonna just make
this into a ungroup ungroup mutate topic
equals as a factor topic ok oh that was
those pretty fast I thought that was
gonna take a while I confused extracting
the topic probably the term
probabilities with the actual generation
of the topic model so fig dot hi equals
10 big dot with equals 10 OOP okay
it's our first topic it's all about
article Supervisory Authority so these
are kind of the same same things let's
see if there's anything that's really
distinctive paragraph is a word
processing control or processing data
processing control what I'm seeing here
is that there's actually not a good way
to actually create topics so it seems
like all all of these articles are very
similar and in topics which which kind
of make sense it'd be kind of weird if
they they kind of delve thousand
something else what we're gonna do still
is and we're gonna assign these topics
to the actual articles so this is to do
that we're gonna switch beta to gamma
boom and it's C so each document looks
at the topic and then they assign it a
gamma probability so what's what we're
gonna do is when they do a group I
document top and gamma and we'll say N
equals 3
so we were gonna sign it three topics
actually we'll assign it one topic that
makes sense okay and then we're going to
ungroup it and we're gonna count wanna
count doc you mean uh and then we'll
just count the topics so it seems like
an even distribution of topics let's see
let's just - uh well it's kind of
interesting cuz there's a hundred
document so maybe we could do like a
range arrange topic and then document
interesting hmm okay trying to figure
out a good visualization for this I got
an idea ggplot a s x equals document y
equals topic color equals topic plus
geum giome point and then as that factor
and then yeah yeah that makes sense plus
theme legend dot position equals nine
and then plus theme minimal
okay okay plus theme okay that's okay
whatever hello how do i how do i just
said move vertical and horizontal grid
and GD p-- y scale X okay plus scale X
continuous breaks equals set scale y
discreet equals breaks he goes nope
sweet okay so what I'm trying to do is
we know it's kind of going in descending
order right we can see the topics we're
like okay we have this topic maybe now I
didn't would you wouldn't know okay you
said you mutate topic as that now I will
just was what we left so we can see that
the topics for the for the fifth topic
its Roy center around on the beginning
of GDP are however to is definitely in
kind of like the middle so we can see
him where does the topic um belong in
the was it GDP are article I'm gonna put
that too
what with that so GG
each idol where does the topic war do
does each topic feet long in GDP are
sweet actually
yeah okay and now I'm gonna do you go
thing mutate topic he was asked out of
factor topic cool and then we're gonna
remove that topic okay then you my
should know position is it left no top
left okay whatever it was put a top so
we can see where the topics are kind of
centered around but it's not great
because what we were trying to figure
out is kind of this distinguishable
things for the topics so what we're
gonna do is something else well we're
gonna do actually is we're gonna use the
GDP our words and instead of using topic
modeling which is actually kind of
resource intensive we're gonna use a
simpler thing called the tf-idf so
instead of topic modeling let's use
something different count word will will
count every word again for each article
and instead we're gonna actually use it
tf-idf function which is basic finding
rare and can't rare words that are
distinguishable for each each each
article so we'll do that
so we'll say a word Oracle and okay and
then we'll do a group by article group
of article and with your top and I wanna
say T FIF and equals three so we're
finding a three most distinguished
awards for each topic and we'll do
ungroup select article word TF will say
and tf-idf arranged by article and yeah
cool and we'll say - tf-idf okay as I
read that I'd do something but so let's
see here
so instead of using topic modeling
because that's a pretty
resource-intensive way to do things to
find out what are the distinguished
distinguishable words and distinct role
groupings of words for each document
what we're actually going to do is we're
going to use the tf-idf algorithm so
first we can actually do the gdpr
umm words and we're gonna just count for
every article since for the T if I do
you have our algorithm to actually work
you need to have more than one document
so we'll do for every article very cool
we're gonna count the word yeah yeah
and then what's cool about tight X is it
has the tf-idf algorithm in it so what
it says is we had to give it the term
the document which is article and then
the n which is n so now it shows you the
term frequency or the relative term
frequency the inverse document frequency
score and then it combines the score
together which is the the the product
between them which term frequency is the
frequency of the the word in that
article the relative the amount of words
in the article the Emirates document
frequency is the amount of times that
word shows up in the all the other
documents so it's trying to balance out
how rare a word is also being how
frequent word is okay so then we're
gonna do a group by article and we're
gonna do a table and tf-idf and we're
going to find the top three tf-idf words
for each article or the most assuming
four three words for each article so N
equals three cool and then we'll do a
ungroup a ring actually will do range by
tf-idf as minus TF oh yeah and then
we'll do oh wait no we'll just do a
ungroup arranged by article Arctic Col
and minus TFI M so now we have the top
tf-idf score for every article okay so
I'm going to say instead of topic
modeling let's do something simpler and
faster so that's the tf-idf score but if
you notice something it's kind of just
choosing rare words right like the two
words two words in one it's not really
great
which is why they actually used a
different thing which is the tidy low
package which is basically kind of like
a better algorithm for which people view
as a better algorithm then the the
tf-idf algorithm because what it does is
it puts a heavier weight on an actual
term frequency that's basically the
entire idea behind it
so we we don't want just rare words we
want highly frequent words so if someone
says something a lot more than someone
else then it'll actually include that
whereas tf-idf if we say the same words
i say the same word even more it'll
still remove it
so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna do the tiny little package and
I'll probably the tiny little package is
um it's right now not able to do the
install out packages you have to install
it from github so I have to do this but
it is a very very good algorithm to use
especially if you think more frequency
is a distinct is a higher higher highway
distinction is an important feature to
add so we're gonna do that okay so we
have GDP our words we're just gonna copy
this in okay so we have our words
instead of just and now we can just do
um was it tidy low and yeah fine
log-odds and the only thing that's kind
of weird about the function is you
actually just do was it article article
word NN so it kind of is a switch
between it but it's still fine um so
we're gonna still do the same thing more
we're gonna group it by our article top
n log odds N equals three okay on group
arranged by article and - log - a log
it's okay
so what's going on here okay so when we
look at the actual log odds compared to
topic modeling we can see that there's
some differences right first I'm just
gonna assign these to something else and
I just realized I was selling a gdb are
it should be gdpr but that's what matter
so we'll say GDP our TF right and I'll
just throw it in there just so people
can see it uh and we'll call it GDP our
blog and we'll put that in okay so we'll
first let's figure out what are the what
are the differences between GDP our and
GDP like what what words did each of
them recommend different from each other
so that's all we're gonna do is we're gu
I'm T and so I'm going to just select
article and word okay
and it said gbbr TF for the other one
we're gonna do GDP our log so we have
both things and this time we're going to
use a function set diff which is okay
and we're gonna find the differences
between these words or the ones that are
not shared so forget for example
free--free is aware that one of them had
and the other one didn't so in this case
it was um I'm term frequency and we can
see only 89 so out of the 347 only 89
were different which means that a lot of
the times tf-idf analog odds or weighted
a log odds ratio well actually give you
the same results but though include
different factors okay so it's really
dependent on your thing so I'm gonna do
this say what are the different what
predictions are different
right so one way you could do this if
you were say doing something like um
feature engineering for a text model is
you could do both you do a tf-idf as
your regular Iser
for for your words to minimize to reduce
the amount of words that you actually
wanted into your model and you could
also do a log-odds model and you can
compare them and see which one is better
or you just combine both and say okay I
want to find the words that are shared
between tf-idf and log-odds so let's do
that okay so instead of viewing set diff
right okay
what we're going to use is intersect
right and these are the words that are
shared between them right so movement
and protects let's look at it movement
protects for log movement and vertex so
right here is 258 words out of the max
will be 391 so we we reduced already
something we already did some more
reduction on because these three are 91
words are really help distinguish em
each article we're now what it's saying
is these 258 words walk should help
distinguish the article so we did it
even more feature reduction you know
also 200 da is still smaller than both
347 to 391 so we can finally use these
words really as the most distinguished
for words and we actually look at it
alright actually okay let's let's just
count each word what are the most common
words that wrote is T no [ __ ] and what's
a soar equals true we see a lot of these
words only show only a few times do
these words show up more than more than
once
so what's saying is these words are
truly kind of disabled for that topic
some of it is gibberish right so we see
here how we had those like numbers and
stuff but a lot of it seems pretty it
seems pretty straightforward to what it
actually might mean so let me say shared
words
okay so now we're just gonna find out
GDP our text and we'll say I just say
shares and we'll say a wall steal our
article I think that that'll work right
yeah art it go
cool shared words okay Oh shared words
articles so it's saying these are the
distinct four words for each article
okay so yeah I know this is this uh I
kinda went really quick for this tight
Tuesday but I just wanted to go over the
basic topic modeling and tf-idf and
weighted log-odds I think those are all
just the bread and brother and the
fundamentals of text mining and you can
really get go through a lot so yeah um
maybe you look over the well I would do
if if I was doing more stuff I probably
do uh let's see a gbbr techno I do GDP
are violations and maybe even run this
right on the type or or summary so yeah
and if maybe yeah actually now I'm gonna
do right now let's let's just do it
uh no Stoke ins word summary drop equals
true okay so we have the words and then
we'll say select name word okay so we're
gonna do this really fast we're gonna
say count name word find tf-idf word
name and group by name
top and tf-idf and equals three on group
okay and then we'll do select named word
tf-idf cool and then we'll do top and
tf-idf and then N equals 15 n equals 10
well the N equals 10 will say that GD
bought a s x equals word y equals TF yep
Phil equals name plus G um calm I went
over your order of words by I tf-idf
I'll be minus and then plus theme legend
dot position equals 9 axis text dot X
almond text angle equals we'll do 45
okay and then we'll say H just equals 1
okay
and actually we do need the top okay so
we say Portugal most distinguished in
summary is doctors okay Lithuania these
controllers Croatia it's for a forceful
gannets available documentation
kosha merchant so they're doing a bunch
of like of things numbers I would
probably remove numbers but that's not
really a big deal um
you want and then what's cool about this
is we can actually do something even of
course we can do on word and we can say
token equals n grams and then N equals
two
now it's analyzed diagrams right not
available country had data controllers
right we can see something start to
interesting start to pop up let's do N
equals three and let's do five okay so
it's maybe do oh boy okay so what's
saying data controllers had the data so
everything about Lithuania is about the
data controllers and Latvia is the
merchant had and then Portugal just has
a mess of things right so there's a lot
of things that decisions for Portugal so
yeah as you can see that a tf-idf is
very fast it's very easy to go and kind
of scale through it you can you don't
even have to just do a generic bag of
words or generic single words you can
actually do tf-idf or even log odds on
the groupings of words
so yeah I'm I'll see you guys next week
and yeah I yawn